welcome back to another edition of
gadget lab podcast I am Michael colori
and i'm john phillips and we have a
couple devices to show you this week
first up the Samsung Galaxy Nexus phone
this is the new google phone that's
right it is running ice cream sandwich
that's android 4.0 it sort of takes the
best of android 2.3 the best of
honeycomb the tablet operating system
and improves upon all that and delivers
a nice cool tasty ice creamy package in
this thing right here so this is the
first place you can get it right that's
right and the phone is a really big deal
but probably the bigger deal than the
actual hardware is the operating system
itself this is the operating system so
yeah I spent the last 24 hours playing
with it it's got a cool of it's got a
ton of cool new features a lot of
interesting animations one animation
when you're scrolling through your
photos or maybe tiles of your friends
when you get to the very end and you
can't go any further the icons sort of
like jitter a little bit as if to say
hey I can't be pulled any more like
leave me alone stop those so that's a
cool animation it's got this people
feature where essentially all throughout
the OS you have these little fun nails
of your friends and their big high-res
photos you can click on it and sort of
get to their most recent social media
activity let's say you're in the email
app you can the email comes in you see
it came from Mike glory I click on your
picture and port nificant for me but if
I wanted to reply I could and I wouldn't
have to email back i could click one of
your little social media icons and
either tweet you back or google+ you
back or text you back so it's sort of a
like a consolidation of all of your
address book information right auto all
across spread across all the different
places you would need it in the only
right and it's got pretty deep hooks
into google plus two which you know is
it makes perfect sense given that this
is
android phone and android is all Google
so there's that there's tons of really
cool photo editing options there's a
panorama mode so you could essentially
take your phone you know go like this
and get a panorama image yeah I mean
it's just tons it's full of tons of
really cool stuff and for all those
people who are worried about breaking
that two gigabyte data limit you know
because your provider your carrier will
will really you know sting you badly if
you if you exceed that limit there's
even new features that let you that
essentially give you an alert when
you're about to cross that threshold and
you can even set it so that you can't
even use that much data so there's also
the facial of lock feature right there's
facial unlock and so you know hold the
phone up and it's like it's like the
James Bond pass right so in a nutshell
you you when you first get the phone you
let it scan your face like that and then
when you hit your lock screen in the
future you hold it up again and it's
supposed to unlock the phone so it works
about eighty percent of the time but it
also can be spoofed so that if you hold
up a photo of your face the phone will
unlock because that happens all the time
it happens in my nightmare espionage
scenarios right so you know for the
super paranoid beware a citizen luck so
the all these crazy features these are
things that are going to appear on the
actual vanilla version of Android right
so when this rolls out to other phones
probably early next year right we're
going to see sort of skin yeah done by
like the HTC yeah rolls of the world
inevitably they're going to skin it but
you know I actually think the the the
baseline experiences is really good and
it'll be a shame if it's over skinned
but yeah it's supposed to come on the
droid bionic the motorola droid razr the
motorola xoom which is a tablet is
supposed to get it because remember this
OS is destined for both tablets and
and all those devices you mentioned our
motorola device right well Samsung
Galaxy 2 s.o that'll get it I always mix
up the two in the S but that's going to
get it to an HTC Rezound is supposed to
get it oh but these are all just you
know rumors and hearsay to this point
right now the Samsung Galaxy Nexus is
the phone that has it so do we are
pricing and availability on that we
don't I you know I got we got the phone
immediately and it did not come with
pricing and availability i emailed our
google contact and they were very vague
so no we don't have it but can I
speculate please do I think it's going
to be three hundred bucks on contract so
you know it is the flagship phone it's
the google phone thing you're going to
want yeah and i like all the other top
in google phones or sorry all the other
type in android phones are 300 these
days like the Rays writer right you know
the industrial design is awesome i'm not
sure if the camera can pick it up but
it's got the sort of curved face it's
big huge screen so yeah i'm really
liking this phone it's very pretty
enough about the phone let's go talk to
Christina about music hi Christina I'm
like one time you see totally let's uh
talk about the updates in the music
services world this week yes we had two
big ones this week itunes match in
google music so i'll start out with
iTunes Match twenty-five dollars a year
you can store twenty-five thousand songs
in iCloud so this is the songs that are
I already have my iTunes library right
so these are ones that aren't purchased
from itunes ok so it's how it works is
it scans your library if a song that you
have downloaded so you ripped it from a
CD or you got it from some other
I tune source if they have it in iTunes
then they'll use the iTunes copy in
iCloud if they don't then it'll upload
your version so it just cuts down on the
amount of time that it takes to upload
all those songs right so why the hell
would I want to do something like that
if you have different devices and you
want to get you music on all those
devices you know your macbook ipad
iphone it stores your music and iCloud
and so you can download songs from
iCloud to each device and you don't have
to download each phone separately from
your computer each of those devices was
going to a pod which is pretty awesome
so what about google music so Google
Music it's been around for a while but
it's been in beta so now it's out of
beta it's a free service and you can
store up to 20,000 songs on their
servers and it's also adding google
music songs to android market so you can
download songs from the answer anymore
so it's a music store within Android and
there's also a nap and Android app and
so you can access your songs and as
opposed to on Apple you have to download
each of those songs to your device from
iCloud with Google Music you're actually
streaming it from the cloud so that's
probably going to present problems with
carriers yes and right now though with t
mobile devices when you purchase songs
it'll go through your your carrier bill
so you going you do carrier billing for
purchasing that's pretty cool so with
the kindle fire and with android devices
and with apple devices we have three
different competing cloud services for
music and all of them give you an
opportunity to store your stuff in some
corporate data center so i think
basically the data center that you
choose is depending on which device you
own right yeah so that's pretty much it
like if you're an iPhone person you use
iCloud if you're an Android person you
use google music and then it sure it's
not as simple as that but that's
basically what it's going to come down
to for most people
that'll be the easiest integration with
your device all right so if you're
interested in cutting the cord this is a
good development but I think a lot of
people may be a little bit weirded out
because they may happen to have a lot of
songs and their libraries that maybe
they didn't pay for is there any worry
about that uh you'll want to go through
and check out the metadata and if there
if it says you know oh this was you know
downloaded from you know such and such
user you might want to clear that out
and then also if you have more than
25,000 songs you're out of luck but you
can make a separate iTunes library just
picking out the songs you do want to
upload to iCloud I see so like the sink
this batch don't sink this parish okay
so I'm going to go home and cover my
tracks but first we're going to bring
John back and take a look at the kindle
fire tablet all right last we're going
to take a look at the kindle fire this
is the the tablet ereader from amazon it
was released this week we were in review
on Monday written by John Phillips the
reviews were mostly mixed John however
did not like it he had a lot of points
that he didn't like so tell us what you
didn't like right okay so it comes from
amazon and it's being marketed as a book
reader in a magazine reader primarily
also a great video playback device so
for video it does kick ass it delivers
great video and there's tons of places
to download or stream video from the
amazon store netflix and hulu plus but
as a magazine reader it pretty much
sucks and so you pull up a magazine and
it's too small to really fit on the
7-inch screen you like comic books and
graphic novels and yeah regular books to
ya kids booooo and all that and for
books it's fine but for magazines which
sort of takes up a whole partition on
their interface the magazines are pretty
much too small to read comfortably on
the device and also when you're you know
pinching in and pinching out it's really
jaggi it's sort of it's almost like stop
motion video at the way it sort of
expands and contracts
now this is interesting because it's
relatively similar to a lot of the
hardware that's out there in more
expensive tablet right right and so from
as far as like what should be driving at
the processor it's got enough firepower
to get the job done but you know you're
a lot of times you'll sort of be poking
at the interface trying to get it to do
something like bring up the home screen
and you and it doesn't react so is it
it's just bad code you know maybe it's
the fact that it's running a platform
environment like a run time in Miami I
don't know but and the other the other
thing too is that Amazon sort of
celebrated its silk browser technology
as something that would supercharged
browsing on this device they basically
sort of split the work load between the
cloud and the local hardware but when
you go to when you go to a web page it
loads really really slowly and adding
insult to injury on top of that when you
swipe you know up down squeeze and
squeeze out that's low 2 and so you know
I'm asking myself this device while it
costs two hundred dollars and it really
is a great bargain you know if it can't
deliver a good web experience which is
the number one thing people do on
tablets then is this two hundred dollars
well spent right if there's one thing
that early adopters know it's that two
hundred dollars is about what you pay
for an aggravating users that's the
going rate darn it I want it so we're
eager to see the next one we will say
that it's I i think it's it's a
promising platform but this
implementation is not the best right and
you know they could updates could
optimize the bad user experience that
I'm talking about yeah then I think
Amazon hears you loud and later all
right we'll be back next week with or
maybe not next week because it's holiday
but we will have a show for you soon
with more gadgets and more gadget news